this one's important as well it's not
about dating and relationships but i
think the message is really really
important it's from a teacher
and let's check it out
see the line where the sky needs to see
it
can you pause that um tyler so we can
read the text
so the teacher she's a teacher and she
has a second job as a server and it says
the teacher to server as a second job
pipeline story today today two tables
didn't tip me i have sixteen hundred
dollars in rant due in five days and i
cried
mid shift midshift okay can't wait to
play restaurant and
broke teacher tomorrow
now what's interesting is when you
scroll down a little bit on that it also
says um
she offers her venmo
for you to send her cash so let me say
this as a former teacher
look at venmo come on man no one's gonna
bail you out honey no one's gonna bail
you out
you're doing something wrong
i feel like adam right now you're doing
something wrong
if you have a job as a teacher and you
have a job as a server and you can't pay
your rent
you need to look at how much you're
doing something wrong what are you
spending money on i noticed a lot of
nice furniture up in that room is that
your room are you but you're buying
something are you are you going out for
drinks are you eating a lot of dinners
out
are you in a place you can't afford and
that rent is too high
like you decided to get the duplex and
you something's going on
you're spending money did you buy you
know maybe
a little too much money at rent the
runway or wherever it is
own up
oh no
when i was a teacher i had a second job
i told you guys as a uh private tutor i
used to run and you know do a lot of
crazy it was insane the schedule my rent
was 1800 bucks a month back then it's a
long time ago but
i sacrificed
i made a decision i'm going to buy this
i'm not going to buy this
i'm going to put my money toward rent
because i want to live by myself i don't
want a roommate and as a result i'm not
going to eat out all that much in new
york city and i don't i didn't really
drink so that was easy for me
can you imagine
she took a lot of heat for that because
people were like i'm not gonna give you
money
but this is something that's happening
among millennials too there's this
expectation of like oh my life is so
hard
oh my life is so hard i don't know i'm
too i just don't have enough money
watch what you're spending and videos
like this don't make you look good
they don't make you look good people
don't feel sorry for you they know
you're doing something wrong you got two
jobs or you know what maybe maybe you
get a different second job
i know this is going to become about you
don't care that teachers don't get paid
enough money i do i'm the one sitting
here advocating for teachers good
teachers to get paid more and shitty
teachers to get fired because they don't
belong in the classroom so i am 100
believe that teachers should not be paid
the same when i was teaching they were
like i taught in a private school so
they did have these incremental pay
increases but it was different i
remember the first year i performed
really well and i got a big boost in my
in my raise because it wasn't a public
education system so they didn't have the
same constraints
it wasn't a big salary but your salary
was in part dependent upon your
performance that's how it should be for
teachers as well i don't want teachers
locked good teachers locked into a
system where they don't make good money
they're very valuable
anybody who spends that amount of time
with your kids and really wants to be
there they're incredibly valuable
teachers
but if you've got two jobs and you can't
pay around you're doing something wrong
downsize
you in a one bedroom get a studio figure
it out
figure it out or if you're not happy
with that situation
get a different job go get training go
do something to you listen you get one
life say it all the time empower
yourself do it differently what you
don't do is go on there and be like hey
everything sucks because i have no money
i have two jobs can you venmo me at
not cute
not cute
wasn't cute to me tyler i don't know if
it was cute were you gonna send her some
money in her venmo no but i think it's
funny that she turned off the comments
yeah of course right it had 408 and then
she shut them off don't you love that
what imagine what the 408 said they were
probably like honey
i didn't read comments i never read the
comments because i don't want it to like
sway my own commentary on the issue but
i didn't see that that's funny
so there you go that's like on twitter
when they like somebody puts up a tweet
and then they're like only people who
follow blah blah blah can respond to
this tweet okay so you're embarrassed by
what you wrote you don't want to delete
it because if you delete it then
everybody will know that you know that
it was really stupid
so now you gotta block who can answer
because you're you know five inside
stupid just take the video down if
you're gonna do that everybody knows
that you you don't let people if you
stop the commenting like that it's
because you got comments you don't like
and now you're upset just pull it down
if that's the case honestly if you like
the short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]
you